centre val de loire vous le savez c'est
la terre des châteaux par excellence
alors il y en a de très célèbres on en
parle tout le temps partout dans le
monde et puis il y en a d'autres qui
sont bien moins connu c'est le cas du
château de fontenay dans lequel je vous
emmène aujourd'hui
nous sommes sur la commune de bléré en
indre et loire alors ce château il est
une histoire étonnante extraordinaire il
plonge ses racines au coeur du 11e
siècle au départ c'était un simple
moulin mais avec des vertus tout même et
puis au fil des siècles au fil des
acquéreurs et bien c'est devenu un
château mais malheureusement le drame
arriva au 19e siècle ce château a été
complètement dévastées mais aujourd'hui
fort heureusement il a retrouvé tout son
apparat et s'est même dotée d'un domaine
viticole
[Musique]
mais
bienvenue à fontenay je vous emmène dans
le grand salon un grand salon totalement
reconstruit en 1871 car pendant la
guerre les prussiens l'avait incendiés
vingt vaches et
ils ont incendié en représailles parce
que les blés roi à l'époque non on
refusait de payer la taxe qui le
demandaient et en plus ils se sont fait
chasser de france qui s'ils ont perdu la
guerre donc pas contentes de quitter le
coin ils ont brûlé le château et toute
cette partie ouest du château à brûler
donc tout ça c'était vraiment des ruines
y avait plus rien le sauveur s'appelle
auguste bic est un peintre et architecte
parisien en vingt ans il va rebâtir la
demeure fontenay retrouve la vie
à cette époque il était jeune architecte
il le mettait à profit les nouvelles
technologies dfl avec le faire et il
était en train de construire dans le
centre de bléré des maisons avec cette
nouvelle technologie
donc il était sur place quand le château
a brûlé et il a donné un gros chèque ou
mer pour le féliciter de sa bravoure
pour les personnes et ses kids et donc
été privés d'emploi et en disant si vous
le permettez je re construire est le
château plus beau que ce qu'il n'était
[Musique]
pas prévu que les propriétaires vont se
succéder avec plus ou moins de bonheur
laissant parfois les lieux sans
entretien une lente agonie suivra jusque
dans les années 2000 la vigne apparaît à
cette époque philippe et nathalie carli
décident d'habiter le château et en font
une vraie maison de famille fontenay
retrouve une âme et s'ouvre même aux
touristes avec des chambres d'hôtes
[Musique]
j'adore cette vue
elle est sereine
[Musique]
film car les bonjour bonjour vous êtes
l'heureux propriétaire de ce domaine là
on est dans le fameux vignoble alors il
ya une chose qui est très frappante
c'est que l'histoire du château de fond
mais a été tumultueuse voire chaotique
assez étonnante
comment se dessine son avenir
d'un côté depuis qu'on est là depuis
2006 on a largement ouvert le château
même si effectivement c'est un château
privé donc on ne visite pas mais on l'a
d'abord rapprocher de la ville
et pour faire des événements communs et
puis c'est vrai on projette
ce château pour que ce soit un beau
domaine viticole mais qui respecte son
histoire c'est pour ça qu'on s'est lancé
dans une démarche
deux
autres valeurs d'agriculture raisonnée
on est même qualifiée à haute valeur
environnementale
et est en fait pour favoriser la
biodiversité dire que par exemple oui
vous respecter l'environnement et on
peut le voir vous ne vous ne levait pas
l'air de vous laisser cette table en
fait on on ne désherbe plus où on est on
est on plante même de la jachère
militaire pour favoriser la biodiversité
oui parce qu'il il faut savoir qu'il ya
des ruches juste juste derrière les
actes eux mans des ruchers et du reste
on peut déguster le miel du château
directement sur place vous savez quoi ça
sent que vous voulez mais ce château
belles fesses je dois dire que on est
tombé amoureux avec mon épouse nathalie
lorsqu'on a visité ce lieu et on essaye
petit à petit de de le faire
devenir vraiment un lieu qui respecte la
culture de la région mais mais qui aussi
offre des vins de très grande qualité
rassurez moi il ya eu beaucoup beaucoup
de propriétaires à fontenay vous
souhaitez rester quelques années encore
avait coûté déjà on est là depuis 2006
et on a bien prévu de passer notre
retraite ici et bien que votre retraite
soit heureuse lorsqu'elle arrivera merci
donc merci
à part pour les habitants de bléré je
suis persuadé que vous ignoriez
complètement l'existence du château de
fontenay demain changement de décor et
changement de lieu également je vous
emmènerai dans le loir et cher raconte
roi en sologne à la découverte du
château de fougères sur bièvre ce
château on le doit à pierre de refuge
qui n'était autre que le conseiller du
prince d'orléans et argentier de louis
ix 11 à demain